before the presentation of the next
award which is in the category of sound
I'd like to tell you that the Board of
Governors has voted a special
achievement award for sound effects
editing of the Black Stallion to mr.
Alan splint
he is unable to be here tonight it it
always happens first George C Scott
doesn't show then Marlon Brando and now
Ellen split
but Mr splett wherever you are will see
that your Oscar gets to you
congratulations and now the beautiful
and dynamic
sally kellerman and with her an Oscar
winner for his tremendous performance in
the heat of the night Rod Steiger
for the best achievement in sound Walter
Murch mark burger Richard Biggs and that
boxer Apocalypse Now
Arthur pianted OC less fresh Holtz
Michael Minkler and Al Overton for the
electric horseman William McCoy Aaron
Rochin and Michael J coho and Jack
Solomon for meteor Robert Knudsen Robert
J glass down McDougald and Jean Cantor
Messer for 1941 theater a Thunderbird
Douglas Williams Paul wells and Jim Webb
for the roles Sally would you open the
envelope please I'd be delighted Ryan
and the winners are Walter Murch
thank you very much
the missing ingredient in the sound
award is the contribution of the sound
editor and in Apocalypse Now the
contributions of dozens of editors and
assistants was so massive that I'd like
to thank them all collectively tonight
and in particular single out rich
Eastern Sione les Hodgson Pat Jackson
and les Wiggins I hope they all realize
that this award belongs as much to them
as it does to us who stand here on the
stage thank you those of us who put
together and all the work of the editors
also had many assistants and I would
like to specifically thank Tom Scott and
Dale strawpoll at all the people at
zoetrope studios and specifically for
personal assistants Susan Wayne Graf my
wife for putting up with my absence for
so long and thank you all for listening
Thank You Frances Thank You Kathy and
Thank You Shelley and thanks to my
family